hey guys what's up I'm Alanna or char
Ilana Zod and today I am making a max
unboxing slash nerd haul video I'm
basically going to be unboxing all of
the statues slash collectibles that I
have managed to obtain during my time in
America we're going to start with I
think smallest to largest I've got a lot
of stuff here and a lot of it was pretty
expensive sizes so the first one that we
have is Super Saiyan Vegeta he was the
cheapest at $20 on ebay so I haven't
opened him yet but being as he was so
cheap I'm kind of that skeptical about
the quality we shouldn't see and out of
G's at homes it's pretty cool you guys
sticky tape yay okay so he comes with a
base plate this thing is not where it
should be so he's actually got two holes
in his back that are holding the you
know power bits up so this isn't where
it should be so I'm gonna try and put it
in without breaking it so he forms like
a little X in front of him I think
that's quite cool I like the color it
seems to be like some degree of shading
on his arm which is quite cool and his
boots as well his face is yeah pretty
good
The Virginian was made by figure of zero
as for standing up on his own on a desk
he stands up pretty much fine he's a
tiny bit wobbly probably not gonna use
the base because they just take up a lot
of room and I find that they often look
really unattractive unless they're ones
that are really nice and stylized this
one's kept quite plain on to number two
guardians of galaxy a Rocket Raccoon and
Groot this one on the box says $54.99
but being that I got it at a convention
which is a great place to buy
collectibles and where it bought a lot
of my collectibles I got it for cheaper
than that so protip for buying
collectibles at conventions is that you
should wait to the final day the
convention goes for a weekend you wait
until the Sunday and then you go to a
store and say I want to buy this thing
all these two things pull this press can
you do it they will usually give you
massive discounts this way you'll get a
cheaper than you can ever get you know
store or that you could ever get
so while this says $54.99 on the books I
actually got it for $40 comes with a
nice little instruction manual really
well looking dismembered seriously so
much sticky tape raccoon came to hit it
that's brutal
all right here is Groot I think that
this is beautiful actually he has like a
lovely kind of Samba expression there's
a little color this is really really
nice but I'll give you a close-up when I
put rocket record on - hey buddy you got
a head that's what she said
totally oh my God he's still missing an
arm here we go all levels intact so this
guy also is shaded quite nicely he's got
like actual indentations for fur now to
put him on dose group maybe I should
have kept the instructions this isn't as
obvious as I thought it would be what
does the box a Guardians a symbol a lot
smaller than I thought it would be but
considering the price that's totally
acceptable this was made by Kotobukiya
so this one is actually a model kit so
presumably you could buy it
unpainted and put it together yourself
which makes it a lot cheaper generally
but I don't like to because I don't
trust myself with paint so if anyone
who's interested in it is an artifacts
110 scale statue made by credit baqia
it's part of the guardians of the galaxy
line and obviously is Rocket Raccoon and
Groot - now and a lot to go d break so
the next one we have here is kind of a
lazy one didn't we come in a box because
I only bought the statue by itself when
it was originally part of a collector's
edition this is team Noble from Halo
Reach I really love Taylor reach so I've
wanted this for quite a while and I
found it very very cheap on eBay as a
bidding option as opposed to a different
kind of option but it was about $40 it's
big it's very plasticy the paint job
isn't great and there's not a whole lot
of detail on it I don't think that this
is worth a whole lot but $40 and for
something that is part of a game and I
really really enjoyed having at it poor
things that are parts of collector's
editions you are best to find them if
you
you want them on the eBay or Amazon or
Craigslist or some kind of you know
later selling website it's always a
place to find them immediately after the
game comes out they will be extremely
expensive so don't buy them then if you
wait a few years they will still be
there and will be much much cheaper next
in line is yet another figure out statue
this is from the same line that the
jitta was but I actually bought him in a
different place this is a freezer in his
final form even spelt the Japanese way
freezer no razor I have been looking for
a freezer for so so long that when I was
browsing Kinokuniya bookstore in New
York City I couldn't not buy it I got
this guy for $60 which I'm totally happy
with considering I've never seen him
anywhere else I probably would have paid
a little more than that so he also has a
base similar to Vegeta did amazing oh my
god I'm so in love with this which you
can tell by the fact that as soon as I
pull them out my hand was automatically
right there that's probably bit too fond
I love that these are nice and
see-through I guess same as the way that
Vegeta is well that the color just makes
it so much prettier but does he pause
the stand-up test he does not stand up
when he's already tips forward which is
a huge shame again might be able to fix
up with some tack but for him I probably
will keep the base beautiful I love the
pose I love his expression I love the
colors I love the shine very very happy
with this decision next up we have my
halo 3 steel spotting this one was made
by kotobukiya I also bought him at a
convention for $100 after having watched
him online for quite a while and $100
the cheapest that I've ever seen for it
so I decided to buy it as you can tell I
tend to like to watch things on it why
don't one time before actually buying
them because it would suck to find it a
lot cheaper somewhere else a day later
you know so if it's something that's not
in limited supply then I will wait for
it this guy does not want to come out of
his box that's a big old spot here he is
he came with some molds but does come
with some other stuff there's a hand
and g.soul in there I think how much
with the energy sold on oh my god that's
so cool the forward on and it goes on so
I'm just gonna wiggle this around make
sure I don't break it obviously to that
and then we select this one in awesome
so how does he look again feels quite
plasticky I'm aside from the energy
sword I don't think this thing is likely
to break on me as for detail you know
it's all that has a nice kind of shine
to it it's kind of metallic some marks
of wear and tear but no obvious shading
and I'm not a huge fan of the visor
which is just a plain color where I feel
maybe it should be a little bit more I
don't know shiny shiny I think it's the
right work but I do really really like
to pose any interchangeable hand that's
a lot to it so I think this one is a
pretty good find we have a lot more to
go so maybe I will actually split this
into two videos will do part 1 and part
2 so that is the end of part 1 I hope
you guys enjoyed it and I will have part
two with more expensive bigger stuff
coming soon I'm a lot of thank you guys
for watching and I will see you next
time